dans un message publié sur facebook à la
fin novembre
le premier ministre albertain a été très
clair non la vaccination contre la copie
ne sera pas obligatoire en alberta parce
que les provinces au le pouvoir
d'obliger la population à se faire
vacciner en noix au québec qui permet
l'obligation de vacciner dans des
situations exceptionnelles de crise
sanitaire ou non pas la collaboration de
la personne mon chien vous directement
ne jamais utiliser c'est pas du tout
dans nos cartons la vaccination
obligatoire est une question qui divise
sur les 3 mai canadiens interrogés dans
le cadre du sondage ipsos radio-canada
56 % se disent en faveur de cette mesure
si on rend obligatoire ce sujet des
personnes qui vont patron mais il n'ya
34 % des canadiens qui s'opposent à
l'idée
j'aime poste quand c'est obligatoire
obliger les gens faire quelque chose on
va se ramasser avec un autre problème la
vaccination obligatoire est une solution
dangereuse de dernier recours disent les
experts
c'est à mon avis l'option nucléaire ou
van à l'extrême une telle mesure
risquerait d'ébranler encore plus la
confiance à l'égard du vaccin
c est ce qu a fait braquer les gens les
jambes
non parce que ses obligés ça alimente
des théories du complot ou juste
méfiance dans les acteurs de santé
publique donc ça c'est hyper dangereux
si la vaccination obligatoire ne semble
pas une option pourra t'on limiter
certaines activités uniquement aux gens
vaccinez les voyages par exemple 60 %
des canadiens seraient d'accord à ce que
seules les personnes vaccinées puisse
prendre l'avion
vous direz oui pour l'avion
et allez voyager des trucs comme ça je
dirais que en australie le patron de la
compagnie aérienne qantas a déjà annoncé
que le vaccin sera obligatoire pour tous
les voyageurs étrangers autre industrie
durement touché par la crise le monde du
divertissement à saint-jérôme le théâtre
gilles vigneault n'a accueilli qu'un
seul spectacle avec public en 9 mois
puis ce qui nous a fait le plus mal dans
l'année pourrait-on rouvrir les salles
aux gens vaccinez seulement 56 % des
canadiens sont d'accord mais le
directeur général du théâtre doute que
ce soit une bonne idée on tombe dans une
logistique qui qui paie pour avoir assez
simple mais qui est assez lourde on a
fait contrôler les gens à quel moment la
chope de bière au moment où ils rentrent
ici ça pose encore une fois des
questions éthiques
pour ce qui est des écoles 59 % des
canadiens pensent que la vaccination
devrait être obligatoire pour aller en
classe mais des médecins comme la
docteure couach sont clairement contre
l'idée pour l'école certaines maple
parce que les enfants plus de risque de
maladie sévère
il ya aussi une majorité de canadiens
qui croient que le vaccin devrait être
obligatoire pour aller travailler au
bureau après ce qu'on peut pour forcer
une personne à se faire vacciner
le président de la csn rappelle que
l'employeur n'a pas le droit d'imposer
la vaccination mais en même temps on
pourrait parler d' obligation morale
pour la population en général
dans certains milieux de travail comme
dans le secteur de la santé refuse et se
faire vacciner pourrait entraîner des
sanctions
en 2009 le tribunal a donné raison à
l'employeur d'une infirmière de rimouski
qui a été suspendu sans salaire pour
avoir refusé d'être vacciné contre le
h1n1
ils suivent à 100 maisons neuves radio
canada montréal